leader of the house thank you uh mr
speaker may i join the honourable lady
and i'm wishing people a happy diwali i
hope that they enjoy their celebrations
um i think there's a problem mr speaker
with people writing their questions
before they have heard what has been
said because i actually made quite clear
in my business statement that we need to
proceed on a cross-party basis and it is
a matter of regret that there was no
cross-party agreement uh yesterday but
obviously a committee cannot a committee
cannot work effectively without
opposition
members on it and that i think was
absolutely clear from from what i said
we need to ensure that we have standards
in this place that are fair and robust
and are seen to be fair and robust and i
would highlight the icgs system which
has an appeal body the independent
experts panel and the independent
experts panel has on it a high court
judge somebody of the highest standing
and legal training but that does not
exist in standards cases and this is
something that has been bubbling away
for some time as people have seen the
differential between the two but i of
course listened to the debate yesterday
very carefully and the comments that
were made from across the house and i
absolutely recognize that it is
important to proceed on a cross-party
basis to have the highest standards
within this house but ones that when
they are implemented are fair to those
to whom they are implemented upon and
that is what we will
seek to achieve and i hope that the
honourable lady and others will be
willing to enter into this in a spirit
of cooperation
as we did successfully
with um her predecessors
over the icgs question to ensure that it
could be actually taken out of the
standards committee and moved
moved although under the umbrella of the
standards committee moved to a much more
independent uh process